- There's a world of
evidence, both scientistic,
and by scientific--
- No, no, no, you can't say scientific.
It's not scientific!
- There's a world of evidence,
both hard and anecdotal and by hard--
- You can't even say hard.
- I can say hard!
- It's soft.
- Nah, it's rock hard.
- It's the softest
evidence there ever was.
- It's hard as a rock.
- It's see-through.
- The evidence I've stated
is it's hard as a rock.
- It's like cellophane, baby!
(paper rustling)
- Hi.
I'm Aria.
I'm a production assistant.
Shane has asked me to read this.
Welcome to Debatable.
In the interest of a
fair and balanced debate,
Shane has excused himself
from hosting duties.
He was unable to remain on the sidelines
for this particular outing.
Are ghosts real?
It's debatable.
(triumphant music)
- [All] Ghosts are real.
- [All] Nope.
(intense music)
- First off, I want to say you've done
a major disservice to
ghosts by dressing them up
in this weird Halloween costume.
- That's ghosts!
That's what you believe in.
- That's not what ghosts are.
- I hate the word ghost, really
because it's like, you think of Casper.
- Yeah, I love Casper.
He's great.
He's also a fictional
character in a movie.
- It's so wildly arrogant to think
that we have it all figured out right now.
- There's a lot of unexplained
mysteries in the world.
Ghosts aren't one of them.
- We have countless stories of people
that we know, trust and love
who have seen them and felt them.
- I don't know, trust or love
anyone who has seen a ghost.
- Look man, I'm not sitting
here trying to say 100 percent.
- What are you trying to say, then?
- I'm saying--
- You're saying.
- You never know.
- There's footage of it.
There's footage of
ghosts caught on camera.
There's footage of things
moving on their own.
- You guys gotta look
into the YouTube videos.
I hate the way I sound right now.
- When I was a kid, there
used to be these two ghosts.
One was short with a hat
and one was much taller
and they were friends?
- This sounds a lot
like imaginary friends.
- We have several EVPs caught on camera.
Those are disembodied voices.
- EVPs are the sound of literally anything
in a room going (groans).
- No.
- And then Ryan going, oh!
- What do you sit at your
computer and do all day?
- I make videos.
- You manipulate footage?
- I'm not believing those
YouTube videos either, my man!
I'm not walking into--
- You just used a YouTube
video as evidence.
- It's happened to me a few times, right?
Where someone has passed
or like an animal.
Sometimes I would dream of them.
- I had a dream about fricking
being friends with Sara Bareilles.
I never listen to her music.
- I could go to any 10
random doors in the world.
About half of them will
say yeah, ghosts are real.
- Half the people in the world
think the sun revolves around the earth.
How many of them just spilled a coffee
and were like, oh!
Sammy Davis Jr.'s in my living room!
- You don't get any sort
of, oh I hope my house
isn't built on an ancient burial ground.
- I grew up across the
street from a cemetery.
I was never afraid of it.
- Baby boy.
- There's so much evidence
when it comes to scientific--
- Don't say scientific.
'Cause it's not scientific.
- It's scientific if--
- Have they ever reproduced in a lab?
- I bet you there's a
fair amount of scientists
who believe in ghosts.
- I bet you there's not.
And if it is, it's probably
some fucking horticulturalist
making green beans in a lab somewhere.
I don't know anything about the human body
but I bet ghosts are real!
- No one in their right
mind wants to see a ghost
unless they're making money--
- Ryan Bergara wants to see a ghost!
- I threw a ball down a
hallway that had hundreds,
literally hundreds of
doorways and windows.
It lands in a hallway that
has my name painted on it.
How is that possibly not evidence?
- Your little mind here, it jumps around,
it connects all the little dots
in a way that is batshit crazy.
- What?
- You've been in those
moments where you question it.
Where it's just like, but what if?
And that's the best part about it.
The je ne sais que of life.
Ooh, maybe ghosts are real!
Ooh, it's fun, whimsy.
- Have you never walked
into a room and been like,
ugh, there's something
dark about this place.
- Yeah.
If there's no lights on.
Zing!
- I do think it's fun.
Halloween's my favorite holiday.
- Yeah, baby.
That's what's up, dude!
We're back!
- But, at the end of the day--
(they laugh)
- I think a ghost could come in here,
pick you up, rock bottom you
into this stupid ghost here
and you'd still say,
what a weird phenomenon--
- To be fair, I've asked
them to a thousand times.
And they've never done it.
- Yeah, 'cause the
logistics of you are weird.
You're eight feet tall and well, floppy.
- Yes, I am floppy.
But that's neither here nor there.
- That's kind of here.
(intense music)
- You know the difference between
make-'em-ups in real life, don't ya?
- The burden of proof lies upon you.
And you got nothing, buddy.
- I don't have the facts
and figures in front of me.
But, how many people
die every Goddamn day.
- We live in a surveillance state.
Houses, you set up a little
Nest Cam, you got baby cams.
Everybody's walking around
with cameras in their pockets.
- Our timelines should be flooded
with thousands of ghost pics a day.
We should be tired of 'em!
We should be saying, too
many ghosts on Instagram.
There's too many ghosts here.
- You're not gonna find
a picture of a ghost
on your Outfit of the Day pic.
- Those people, though, with
photos of ghosts, you know?
And they're like, look, it's a face.
And I'm like, it's a bit
of dust, you fuckface.
- Every year that goes
on and we don't have
any sort of video or audio proof,
the case against ghosts
gets stronger and stronger.
- The amount of ghosts
that people have seen
is so small compared to
the amount of people dying.
- Thank God because we'd all be
in a constant state of terror.
- Or would we be so used to them
because they were real and
we were familiar with them
that we'd just be like, whatever.
It's a part of life.
- Oh yeah, like hey, Johnny!
What's up?
- Exactly.
You'd be fist bumping with the ghosts
but your fist would go
through, 'cause he's a ghost.
- We're not seeing this
influx of ghost proof
even though it should
be everywhere nowadays.
- Yeah.
There could be a ghost here right now.
Who knows?
- Oh!
- Look how funny I thought that was.
- You son of a bitch.
- You never see a ghost
just hanging out at a party,
playing pinball, doing fun things
that they didn't get to do.
If you came back, why are
you just sitting in a chair?
Why wouldn't you just be
fricking in Dubai, living it up.
- They are.
There's heaps of ghosts in Dubai.
- Do animals turn into ghosts?
- Yep.
They do.
- Why are you so positive?
- Because there's been
plenty of sightings.
- Are there monkey ghosts?
- Oh, Garrett.
- Are there?
Yes or no.
- Dogs, cats, birds.
- How 'bout toads.
- Uh, no.
You can really cut out the whole phylums.
- Trees.
- Why would there be a ghost tree?
- Why would there be a ghost chipmunk?
- Because a chipmunk has a soul.
I don't think that's a crazy thing to say.
Chipmunk probably has a family.
It has a little wife and
two little chipmunk kids.
- What the fuck are you talking about?
- Yeah, it's flawed.
It's flawed.
It's flawed, baby.
We all know it.
You gotta just go with whatever--
- You're saying?
Whatever nonsense you're
saying, I have to go with it?
- To a degree.
(triumphant music)
- Look.
I respect what Sara has said today.
All I can do is trust myself and I have
and they are real.
A lot of the time, they're not.
But they are.
- I think aliens are real.
- Yeah, me too.
- The burden of proof falls
upon these nutcases over here.
- No, I think it's just as much on you
to prove that ghosts aren't real
as it is for me to prove
that ghosts are real.
- The thing is, it's not.
- Again, say it with me, you never know.
- I do.
- The arrogance!
When you start talking
about ghosts, you get mean!
You get downright mean.
Look at me!
You hear me?
(laughing)
This is insane.
(triumphant music)
- You don't get any weird vibes
when you're in a cemetery?
(speaking gibberish)
- [Garrett] You can't
just do that every time.
There should be a Debatable penalty box
and you're in it, buster.
Alright?
(sign squeaking)